Fabien: Mais dis donc,
Ce serait pas un Brésilien?
Julien: Mais si, totalement!
F: C'est Julien Loza, mon pote du Brésil
Il est venu spécialement pour le meet-up d'aujourd'hui!
Bon ok, il n'est pas venu du Brésil exprès pour le meet-up
Mais le fait est qu'il est arrivé hier
Qu'il avait réservé sa place
Avec le décalage horaire tu as pris ta place à quelle heure toi?
J: Heu... Sur place j'ai pris ma place il était dans  les 5-6h du matin
Quelque chose comme ça je crois
F: Ah ouais 5-6 heures
T'as vu? c'est pas beau l'amitié ?
J: C'est la première fois que je suis dans le métro, avec une caméra juste là, sous mes yeux,
c'est super stressant.
**Générique**
F: Au 1er janvier j'avais  lancé le mental vlog en disant je vais faire une vidéo par jour,comme ça, tranquille
mais on était un abonné...
c'était ma mère
Et euh... et là on est quand aujourd'hui  ?
on est le 12 octobre
Et on est le 12 octobre et on est à 137 000 abonnés. MERCI
Et ça c'est grâce à vous
Et comme prévu, je vais faire mon meet up au Youtube    space
évidemment pour ceux qui ne sont
pas là et qui ne sont pas à Google aujourd'hui,
je vous emmène avec moi
regarde: c'est pas trop joli ça?
Ça c'est Marine Baousson
Parce que tout le monde croit que mon meet up je le fais à Paris
En fait on est au dessus de Paris
On est juste ici, là
Un décor hyper High tech... avec un téléphone à touches
3 bouteilles pour 85,
Va falloir gérer les amis hein!
Ça c'est la veste qu'on m'a dit de voler avant de partir
Je te fais une trace vidéo pour que tu la voie une dernière fois mais euh
(une fan)Je t'ai découvert il n'y a pas longtemps mais c'était vraiment la découverte de l'année
continue comme ça, t'es vraiment le meilleur. Et puis une vidéo par jour, t'es vraiment courageux
Donc bonne chance et bonne continuation.
(autre fan)Il paraît que c'est maintenant ou jamais pour te dire quelque chose Alors "quelque chose"
Donatien: C'est hyper VIP ce soir
Alors t'as commencé donc
Le premier janvier. Quesque tu connaissait à youtube, le premier janvier
Quand t'as décidé de te lancer avec ce truc à la con de ...
(rires dans le public)
F: Nan mais c'est ça : je ne savait pas qu'on avait plus de vie après
D: ton challenge:
Une vidéo par jour pendant un an, l'année bissextile en plus.
F: Oui c'est Verino qui me l'avais fait remarqué
Il fallait l'annoncer publiquement parce que comme ça si je ne le fait pas, il y a tout le monde qui va faire "ah! ah!"
Tu sais comme dans les simpsons :"AH! AH!"
D: Quand tu regardes tes premières vidéo, tu...?
F: Je ne regarde pas mes ..(rires dans le public)
D: alors fait le, et filme-toi
F: On faisait un plateau pour mademoiselle.com, le site
C'est Marine Baousson qui organise ça. Il n'y a pas d'artistes...
Et il y a une meuf qui s'appelle Lola dubini
et donc on se rencontre on se marre
en loges tout le long
voilà, qui fait partie aussi de cover garden et qu'a une chaine solo
Et on se rencontre là-bas et" wah je suis en première c'est cool"
Et on parle, on parle, et elle fait: tu fais quoi?
Je fais :"bah en même temps, je fais des vidéos sur YouTube et elle fait "ah moi aussi! trop bien!"
On commence à discuter, de créateur à créateur :
-Ah  t'as combien d'abonnés?(lola)
-Ouais, je crois que j'ai 17 000 abonnés c'est cool
**rires**
-Mais putain c'est ouf, c'est trop bien et tout...
-Eh ouais ,je pèse dans le game...
**rires**
Et puis, je te jure que c'est vrai: à un moment donné, elle va aux toilettes
Et tu sais, je regarde vite fait: Lola dubini
donc 300 000 abonnés ok ...
**rires**
elle était hyper humble, tu vois...
-Et euh pareil, c'est en sortant du plateau, elle fait ah mais j'aimerais trop qu'on fasse une vidéo ensemble (Lola)
T'es d'accord?
-écoute...
D: Je regarde mon planning
F: Si je peux aider les gens... non, non
Elle est Hyper sympa
Elle a fait un truc qu'a vraiment cartonné en tout cas de mon point de vue
Puisqu'elle a fait doublé ma chaîne: j'étais à 17 000 et je suis passé à 34 000
déjà j'avais toujours en stock mes 7 vidéos sur le rubik's cube
que j'avais tourné ici au mois de février
au cas où un jour je serai malade
Je me dit : mais si je suis malade, je fait quoi en fait? je publie quoi?
Moi, dans moi lit: "ah! pense à un chiffre ah!
**rires**
J'avais prévu comme ça les 7 vidéos de rubik's cube
si j'ai une galère, je sors ça. Mais j'ai pas eu de galère
et à partir de fin juillet jusqu'au 31 août
Je me dis 'Ok je vais sortir les 7 vidéos de Rubik's cube'
pour aller au festival d'Avignon prendre le temps et tout
et après je vais me prendre un mois où je vais caler mes vacances
et caler tout un travail pour la suite de l'année
et je suis venu tourner, ici, en une journée 32 vidéos
donc dans un studio qui est là bas
D: Tu as le record pour l'instant
*Rires*
F:  Cool j'aime bien les records *rires*
C'est les énigmes de l'été, les 32 énigmes
F: Bon. Je mens pas?
J:  *rires* Non tu mens pas mais c'est... pfff
F: C'est le jour où il m'a demandé d'être témoin pour son mariage
"Parce que tu es au minimum ce qui se rapproche le plus d'un meilleur ami"
J'ai fait Bâtard
*rires*
Je lui ai demandé de faire les images de ça
alors je le découvre avec vous
Vous savez que  c'est ça qui m'a motivé aussi à faire les 100 000. Ça marche trop sur moi ce genre de truc
Yeeeeehhhh
*Applaudissements*
F: Trop bien
Il y a  1/100 000è qui t'appartient, Il y a  1/100 000è qui t'appartient, vous allez pouvoir gratter un petit peu du 100 000
Aujourd'hui il y avait Laetitia
L: Coucou aujourd'hui on est un nouveau jour
et on est un jour de space parce que on fête les 100 000 abonnés de mon ami
Fabieeeennn
F: C'est moiiii
F: Il y avais Raj
*Rires*
Il y avait toi, toi, Alexandre
Colline, je ne connais pas ton prénom?
Florian: Florian
Fab: Salut Florian
Rémy D'Arcangelo, Donatien
D: Tu as passé une bonne soirée?
Laurent Tardieu du LoCo Show
Oui j'ai passé une très bonne soirée
D: Et bien nous aussi figure toi
F: C'était formidable
Merci beaucoup
Ils ont essayé de me faire croire qu'ils avaient pas le trophée à la fin
et moi j'ai...
D: Et je parie qu'on a mal bluffé?
j'ai été gentil,
je ne vous ai pas trop fait galérer, j'ai fait oui et je suis passer à un autre sujet
D: Tu as joué la surprise quand même.
F: [jouant la surprise] Naaannnn oh non. Ouiiiii
*rires*
et j'ai rajouté au marqueur 37
F: Salut, j'ai le droit de te filmer
Q: Oui
F: C'est quoi ton prénom?
Q: Quentin
F: Salut Quentin
Q: Enchanté
F: Merci d'être venu
F: Salut ooohhh.... Clément ben oui bien sûr
*rires*
F: J'aile droit de te filmer?
L: Ouais
F: Salut c'est quoi ton prénom?
L: Linda
F: Linda ça va Linda
L: Coucou
F: Regarde on met des pouces
on met des pouces sur Linda, merci d'être venue Linda
Tu as fait un dislike?
L: Non j'ai pas fait exprès
F: Meuf tu as tellement fait un dislike.
La meuf elle vient à mon meet up, elle fait ça s'il te plait
L: Non c'est pas vrai, c'est 2 pouces même en l'air
Q: C'est un vrai mot
F: C'est un vrai mot d'accord
C'est quelque chose que tu peux visualiser ou c'est un concept?
Q: C'est un concept
F: Un concept
d'accord tu peux penser à la 1ère lettre de ce concept
Q: Oui
F: Ça peut être le A, B, C, D, E, F, G, H
C'est le B mais faut pas lui dire
*rires*
F: Tu me le dis si je me trompe
Tu penses au nombre de syllabes
Q: Okay
F: Okay ça peut être 1, 2, 3
d'accord, il a cligné à 3 ça veut dire que c'est avant 3
c'est avant 3 du coup
ça peut être une syllabe ou 2 syllabes, ça peut être un ou 2 voir 3 ou 2
vous avez vu...
*rires*
Q: Non non je réponds pas je connais le truc. Vas y
F: C'est 2 syllabes?
Le groupe: C'est 2 ou 3 ouais
F: Et ça peut être en 1 lettre, 2 lettres, 3 lettres, 4 lettres, 5 lettres, 6 lettres, 7 lettres.... C'est en 4 lettres.
Est ce que c'est correct?
Q: Ouais c'est fort
F: Un concept en 4 lettres de 2 syllabes c'est 'Bien'
Q: Bravo
J: Wouah bravo très impressionné
F: Pff on a prévu ça depuis un mois
*rires*
et en ça je te remercie. Tu as une chaîne YouTube?
Q: Non
F: Abonnez vous à ma chaîne
*rires*
F: L'abus d'alcool est dangereux pour la santé à conseiller avec précaution à vos amis
vous pouvez leur dire 'Bois un coup' mais fait gaffe
A conseiller avec précautions